North Korea claimed it dismantled its
nuclear test site in the northeast
corner of the country Thursday it
brought a small group of foreign
reporters to watch the explosive closure
of three tunnels used in past blasts
eyewitnesses said it was spectacular but
there were no international experts to
confirm the claims then a few hours
later the real regional bombshell the
cancellation for now at least by
President Trump of the plan summit next
month in Singapore with Kim jong-un
South Korean president moon jae-in who
had been with President Trump earlier
this week discussing the plan summit was
set to be perplexed by the regrettable
news in a statement late Thursday he
said denuclearization can't be delayed
or abandoned urging direct talk again
between the two sides all this is urge
of a moon as he has moved to bring the
crisis to a diplomatic resolution
including his own summit last month with
kim jongwan along the DMZ it's certainly
a significant setback but South Korea
obviously have have reached out publicly
and you know both parties to remain calm
and engage in dialogue regional
observers are still holding out hope
that the two sides can start talking
reasonably with each other again for now
at least experts say they're talking at
each other this is definitely a huge
bump in the road but I suppose we'll
have to wait and see what the North
Korean reaction is as well as what the
reaction of other regional players are
as well it is early Friday morning here
on the Korean Peninsula and so far at
least we have not gotten a reaction yet
from the North Korean government to the
White House moves the regime recently
has gotten a little bit better with its
reaction time but in fact they might
want to consider what could what is next
after this White House decision to Brent
Gregg Velka live in Seoul great thanks